The first material we're going to create is a simple thin glass material.
I'm gonna navigate to my content drawer and in the lighting 203 for our T folder,
I'm just gonna create a new folder and just call it examples.
We'll double click and open that folder and
I'm going to right click and create a new material.
And we'll just name this M underscore thin glass.
Go ahead and double click it and it will open our material editor.
Now from here, I want to adjust a few base settings of the material
to allow it to work properly with path tracer.
So the first thing I'm gonna do is change my blend mode to translucent and
change my shading model from default lit to thin translucent.
Now we will see a couple warnings and this indicates the third step we need to do,
which is change our lighting mode to surface forward shading.
So we can scroll down to our lighting mode and
we're gonna change this to surface forward shading.
Go ahead and hit save.
Now we'll still get a warning here that says the thin translucent materials
requires the use of a thin translucent material output node.
All right, so let's go ahead and add that.
So I'm just going to right click somewhere on the grid itself and
just type in thin and we want a thin translucent material output.
There we go, perfect.
We should see the two settings, hit save.
All of our warnings should disappear right now.
And now what I'm going to do is actually just apply the material to our
example sphere here.
So I'll just open the content drawer and I can simply just drag and
drop it onto our object.
Now we shouldn't see really any changes right now and
we're gonna adjust that by adding some parameters to our material.
So I'm gonna just move this off to the side so we can see and
expand by material window out.
All right, now from here I'm just going to add a few properties.
So the first one that I wanna do for
my base color is just hold down the number three and
left click which will get me a three scalars or R, G and B.
I'm just gonna plug this into our base color, black is fine.
And then I'm gonna hold down the number one and click,
which should give me a single scalar.
And I'm just gonna do that a few more times.
We'll get ourselves four properties here.
Go ahead and plug into our metallic and we'll set this at zero and
plug the next one into our roughness.
Now in this case, I'm going to have a very slight roughness.
So we're gonna do 0.02 and we'll plug in our third property to our specular.
So actually let's go into our opacity.
We can leave specular as the default of 0.5.
So in our opacity, we'll leave this at zero.
And then finally, we're going to plug into our refraction.
Now if you notice that it's disabled, we can enable that if we go back to our
material so we can select the material or click anywhere in the grid.
And what we're going to look for is our refraction mode.
I'm gonna go ahead and just type in refract and right here we have refract
refraction method and on this one we can change it to index of refraction.
And you'll notice now that that property becomes available.
So this is purely optional if you want to use it, you absolutely can.
So in this case, you can set something to we'll do like 1.5.
You'll see that it gives us a slight bit of refraction, which is perfect.
And then finally, the last thing that we wanna do is give our material
a little bit of color.
So I'm just gonna hold down the number three to bring up our three vector.
And you can just double click this, which will open the color picker.
And we'll just give it something like a hot pink, it's totally fine.
And we'll plug this into our transmittance color.
We should see now that this should update.
And because this is a material and not a material instance,
you'll notice a viewport doesn't update until we either hit apply or save.
So I'll go ahead and just hit save and
then we should see our example sphere update with the material.
And if we move it out of the way, you see now we're getting our reflections,
our refractions as we would expect with path tracer.
So this concludes us making the thin glass material.
In the next section, we're gonna go a little bit step further and
create another material with a little bit more complexity.